If we make analogy with natural languages,
if expressions like "tmp" are noun phrases, then operators like "assignment"
are verbs and entire statements like tmp gets 5 are sentences.
This whole thing together is a statement.
It involves two expressions--tmp an identifier, 5 a number--
and an operator--the assignment operator.
Just as I might write the English sentence, j becomes 3--perhaps it's her birthday today,
I can write the JavaScript assignment statement, j becomes 3.
J is assigned the value 3.
Similarity between the syntactic elements--the subject, verb, object, and punctuation.
Subject- verb, object, and punctuation.
Identifier, operator, expression, semicolon is relatively direct.
Now that we have an intuition for statements, let's add them to our JavaScript formal grammar.
One of the most common kinds of statements is the assignment statement
where we have an identifier on a left-hand side of an equal sign
and then an arbitrary expression on the right--x becomes equal to 5.
Another kind of statement is the return statement.
At the end of absolute value or Fibonacci or factorial or almost any function or procedure
we want to return with the final value, return an arbitrary expression
that becomes the value of the function.
There are also statements that influence what gets executed and under which conditions.
Formally, these statements are said to refer to control flow
because they guard how execution flows through your procedure.
The if statement checks to see if a certain expression is true,
and if it's true, then we execute the then branch.
There is also an if then else.
If the expression is true the then branch else the else branch.
I haven't said what a compound statement is, although since we've seen JavaScript before
we're going to guess that it involves those curly braces.
Let's write it out right now.
A compound statement is an opening curly brace, a closing curly brace,
and some statements in the middle.
This is a list of statements terminated by semicolons. I'm going to show you how that works.
Here I've added a recursive grammar rule.
Statements can be one statement followed by a semicolon followed by
as many more statements as you like,
or you can decide that you're done and replace it with nothing.
Or if you like, we'll draw the epsilon there to mean the empty string.
For the subset of JavaScript that we'll be handling in this class,
this grammar gives more details about what's possible.
In addition to expressions, we have statements that build upon expressions.